JavaScript frameworks
are incredibly powerful tools.
They will empower you to build
complicated projects with ease.
They also help teams to get up and
running quickly.
All while maintaining code
consistency and quality.
Before we begin,
I do want to stress two things.
First, is that will be taking a deep
dive into some pretty advanced
JavaScript language features and
programming concepts.
This course builds on web tooling and
automation, JavaScript design patterns
and object oriented JavaScript.
To really get the most
out of the material,
make sure you're comfortable with these
topics discussed in these courses.
Check in the instructor notes for
links to these courses.
Most importantly, make sure you're
comfortable working with JavaScript
objects, especially how prototypal
inheritance works, functions,
how lexical scope works, and
closures with the data hiding
capabilities that they provide.
The second thing i want to stress is
the importance of both watching and
working along with me
throughout the course.
Don't just sit back and watch
the videos, but take an active role,
walk through the code with me and
make sure you actually attempt
the quizzes and challenges yourself.
If you stick with it and
carefully work through the code I
know you'll come out with skills
you can really be proud of.
This is a challenging course.
So if you feel like you're starting to
get overwhelmed in some of the videos,
stop, seriously.
Sometimes all it takes for something
to just click is just to take a break.
Go for a walk around the block.
Do something totally different to clear
your head while I was making this course
it felt like I walked around
the block every single day.
So, ready to get going?
Let's do it.